hello everybody my name is kent and
today we're going to be covering aws
identity and access management also
known as i am
tutorial by simply learn
so these are the topics which we'll be
covering today
we'll be defining what aws security is
the different types of security in aws
what exactly is identity and access
management
the benefits of identity inaccess
management
how
im works
its components
its features and at the end we're going
to do a great demo on i am with
multi-factor authentication and users
and groups
so without any further ado let's get
started
so let's get started with what is aws
security
your organization may span
many regions or many accounts and
you may encompass hundreds if not
thousands of different types of
resources that need to be secured and
therefore you're going to need a way to
secure all that sensitive data in a
consistent
way across all those accounts in your
organization while meeting any
compliancy and confidentiality standards
that have to be met so for example if
you're dealing with health care data or
credit card information or personal
identification information like
addresses this is something that needs
to be thought out across your
organization so of course we have
individual services in aws which we will
explore
in this video however in order to govern
the whole process at an organizational
level we have aws security hub now aws
security hub is known as a cspm which
stands for a cloud security posture
management tool so what does that really
mean well
it's going to encompass like i said all
these tools underneath the hood in order
to bring a streamlined
way for you to organize and adhere to
these standards across organization
it'll identify any misconfiguration
issues and compliant risks
by continuously monitoring your cloud
infrastructure for the gaps in your
security pulse reinforcements
now why is that important
well these misconfigurations
can lead to unwanted data breaches and
also
data leakages so in order to govern this
at a very high level like i said we need
to incorporate aws security hub that
will automate and manage all these
underlying services for us in order to
perhaps take automated
action we call that remediary actions
and
you can approve these actions
manually or you can automate those
actions as you see fit across
organization so let's delve a little bit
deeper into what is aws security and
then we'll start looking individually at
some of these services
and so
our organization has special needs
across different projects and
environments so of course
the production development test
environments all are gonna have their
own unique
needs however it doesn't matter
which project or which business unit
we're talking about what are their
storage backups needs
they should all be implemented in a
concise standardized way across our
organization to meet that compliancy
we're just talking about so we want to
automate all these tedious manual tasks
that we've been doing like ensuring that
perhaps our buckets and s3 are all
encrypted or all our ebs volumes are
encrypted and we want to have an
automated process in place in order to
give us time
on other aspects of our business perhaps
our application development to bring
better business value and that allows to
grow and innovate the company and a way
that's best suited for it so let's take
a look at the different types of aws
security
now there are many different types of
security services out there however
we're going to concentrate primarily on
i am in this video tutorial so i like to
think of i am as
the glue between
all aws services because by default we
don't have permission for any one
service to communicate with another so
let's just take for example an ec2
instance that wants to retrieve an
object from s3 well those two services
could not
interact unless we interacted with i am
so something that's extremely important
to learn and by the end of this video
tutorial you'll be able to understand
what im is we have amazon guard duty
here which is all about logs basically
aggregates all logs from example
cloudtrail which we still haven't talked
about at the end of this list over here
but instead of looking at cloudtrail
individually guard duty will actually
take a look at trail
cloudtrail we'll take a look at your vpc
flow logs and we'll take a look at your
dns logs and monitor that account and
your network and your data access via
machine learning algorithms and it'll id
and e threat
where
you can automatically remediate the
workflow
that you've approved so for example
if you know of a malicious ip address
that's making api calls well those api
calls are registered in cloudtrail right
so
this machine learning
algorithm will be able to detect that
and take action
so this is really
governed at a higher level than you
having to you know individually inspect
all your dns logs flow logs and cloud
trails individually and take action
through some scripting fashion that that
you've come up with so guard duty
manages all that
we have amazon macy which once again
uses machine learning but also uses
pattern matching pattern matching can be
used with
matching
kind of libraries that are already in
place or you can come up with your own
pattern matching and that's used to
discover
and protect your sensitive data so for
example if you had health care data also
known as hipaa compliancy or credit card
data that's lying around well macy will
discover it and will protect it
so as your data grows across your
organization
that might be harder and harder to do in
your own way so macy really facilitates
uh discovering and protecting that so
you can concentrate on other things aws
config is something that kind of works
in tandem with all the other
services
it's able to continuously monitor your
resources configurations and ensure that
they match your desired configuration so
for example
maybe you state that your s3 bucket
should be encrypted by default all of
them or you want to make sure that your
im
user access keys are rotated and if
they're not then take remediary action
so a lot of these automated remediary
actions right are
basically executed via aws config so
you'll see the aws config actually used
by other services underneath the hood
and then you have cloudtrail cloudtrail
is all about logging every single type
of api call that's made so it'll um
it'll always record the api call who
made it from what source ip um the
parameters that were sent
with the api
the response
all that data which is really a gold
mine for you to
investigate if there's any security
threat and again
this
trail over here and there can be many
and there's lots and lots of data
generated by these trails can be
analyzed by these other services
uh specifically guard duty here
and that automates that process so you
don't have to
so let's get to the next one which is
what is identity and access management
so what is ion
like i said im is the glue between all
aws services
it will
allow those services to communicate with
each other once you
put im into place
the other thing is is it allows to
manage our aws users which are known as
iam users and group them together in two
groups to facilitate
assigning and retrieving or removing
permissions from them
instead of doing it on an individual
scale so of course if you had
200 im users and you wanted in one shot
to add a permission to a group that
contained 200 item users well you can do
that in one operation instead of 200.
now we do have a distinction between im
users and end users end users use
applications online whereas im users
are your employees in your organization
that are
interacting directly with aws resources
so for example an ec2 instance would be
a resource that let's say a developer
would be interacting with and
traditionally those are resources that
are used
full time from nine to five let's say
five days a week 365 days a year okay
now sometimes those users have to
have elevated permissions for a
temporary amount of time and that is
more suited for a role and that will
eliminate the need to create separate
accounts
just for you know
type of actions that are needed for
let's say an hour a month or two hours
a week or something like that something
like backing up an ec2 instance removing
some files doing some cleanups
traditionally you don't have those
permissions as a developer
but
you can be given temporary permissions
to assume this role so it's kind of like
putting a hat on your head and
pretending you're somebody that you're
usually not for a temporary amount of
time once you take off the hat you go
back to being your old boring imuser
self which doesn't have access to
performing backups or cleanups and stuff
like that so
the roles interact with the service
called the secure token service which
gives us specific keys three
specifically an access key a secret key
much like a username and password and
then we have a token key which only
gives you access to this role this
elevated permission for
1 to 12 hours so we'll talk more about
roles
as we go on through this video tutorial
but it's important that you at least
remember at this point even if you don't
know all the details that roles have to
do with
temporary permissions elevated
permissions
so what are the benefits of im
well
across our organization
we are going to have many accounts and
like i said hundreds if not thousands of
resources so scalability is going to be
an issue if we don't have a very high
level
uh visibility and control over the
entire security process
and once we have a tool like for example
security hub which we saw on the first
slide we can continuously monitor
and maintain a standard across our
organization so very very important to
have that visibility
and we do when we integrate with aws
security
now we also need to eliminate the human
factor right so
um
we don't want to
manually
put out fires every single time of
course there will be times when
something new occurs that we've never
seen before that that you know will be
needed however
once an
occurrence happens and reoccurs we can
obviously come up with a plan to
remediate the action so once we automate
we can definitely reduce the time to fix
that reoccurring error or it could be a
new erdogan we don't have to interact
with because we're using machine
learning algorithm services like i was
talking about like our duty or macy
and we can really reduce the risk
of
security intrusions and data leakage and
such by using im to facilitate this
of course you may have many compliance
needs you may be dealing
with applications that use healthcare
data or credit card information for
payments
or
you might be dealing with a government
agency let's say in the u.s that has
certain compliancy
requirements that needs assurances that
if their data is stored on the cloud
that you're still following the same
compliance controls that you were let's
say on premise so we have a very very
long list
of compliance requirements that each aws
service
adheres to and you can go on the um aws
documentation online and you could
figure out if for example
dynamodb is compliant with hipaa
compliancy and it is and so you you can
be sure that you can use that so aws
itself has to constantly maintain these
compliancy controls in place and they
themselves have to pass all these
certifications and that gets passed on
to us so much less work for us to
implement these compliance controls we
can just inherit them by using
aws a security model by im
and last but not least we can build the
highest standards for privacy and data
security
now having
all this on our own
on-premise data center
poses security challenges especially
physical security challenges you have to
physically secure the data center you
might have security personnel that you
need to
hire
24 7 camera surveillance etc etc so just
by migrating to the cloud
we can
take advantage of aws's global
infrastructure they're very very good at
building data centers that's part of
their business and securing them so of
course we have a shared security model
in place however you can rest assured
that at least as the lowest common
denominator
physical security has been put into
place for us again
as other services are used more managed
services or more higher-end services
used in aws more and more of that
security model
will be aws responsibility and less
yours we will always have a certain type
of responsibility for our applications
but we can again use these high-level
services to ensure that our ability to
encrypt the data at rest and in transit
are always maintained by coming up with
specific rules that need to be adhered
to
and if those rules are not adhered to
then we have remediary actions that take
place in order to maintain again that um
cross account or organizational wide
security control okay so lots of
benefits of using i am
and let's now take a look at exactly how
im works and delve deeper into
authentication and authorization
so there are certain terms here that we
need to
know about one of them is principle now
principle is nothing more than an entity
that is trying to interact with an aws
service for example an ec2 instance or
an s3 bucket now that could be
a user an im user it could be even a
service or it could be a role so we're
going to take a look how principles need
to be specified
inside i am policies
authentication
so authentication is exactly how it
sounds who are you could be something as
simple as username and password or it
could involve an email address example
if you're the root user of the account
when you're creating the account for the
very first time
other normal users will not need to log
in with their user
email it'll only be the root user that
needs that
you could also have developer type
access which needs access let's say via
command line interface or a software
development kit also known as an sdk
now for those kind of access
points we're going to need
access keys and secret keys or
public private keys let's say if you
want to even authenticate and log in
through ssh to an ec2 instance so there
are many different types of
authentication that we could set up when
creating im users based on what kind of
access they need do they just need
access to the console do they need
access to just services
in terms of as a programmatic needs
so those are the different types of
authentication
and then we have the actual request now
we could make a request in aws through
various ways
we're going to be exploring that via the
console the aws console however every
button you click every drop down list
you select that invokes
an api call behind the scenes so
everything goes behind a
centralized well-documented api every
service has an api so if you're dealing
with
lambda let's say well lambda has an api
if you're dealing with ec2 ec2 has an
api
now you could interact with that api
like i said via the console
indirectly you could use a command line
interface you can use an sdk for your
favorite programming language like
python
so all of them get funneled through all
your requests get funneled through an
api
but that doesn't mean you're allowed to
do everything just because we know who
you are and you have
access to some keys let's say to make
some api calls you have to be authorized
in order to perform certain actions so
maybe you're only authorized to
communicate with dynamodb and also maybe
you're only authorized to perform reads
and not write so we can get some very
fine-grained
authorization through some i am policies
in order to control
not only who has access
to our aw releases but what they're
allowed to do so very fine-grained
actions read actions right actions both
maybe just describe or list some buckets
so depending on the aws user that's
logged in we can control exactly what
actions
because every api has fine grained
actions that we can control through i am
and of course many many different types
of resource
when we're coming up with these policies
all these
actions can be grouped into resources so
perhaps we can say
well this user only has access or read
only access to s3 specifically these
buckets and can write to
a dynamodb table but cannot
terminate or shut down an ec2 instance
so all these kind of actions can be
grouped into resources on a pro-resource
basis based on the kind of role you have
in
the projects
or in the company
so now let's take a look at the
components of im
we've already seen that we can create i
am users
and that how they are different than
your normal end users
now those entities represent a person
that's working for organization that can
interact with aws services
and some of those permissions that we
assign through what's called identity
based policies to such a user will have
permissions for example that are always
necessary every time that they're logged
in so perhaps this
user tom
always needs access to the following
services over here for example an rds
instance or an s3 bucket etc etc and
sometimes they will need temporary
access to other
services for example dynamodb
so in those cases there would be a
combination of normal i am policies
assigned to the user
and certain
assume role calls done at runtime in
order to acquire this temporary
credential elevated permission
there is also
the root user which is different than
your typical super user administrator
access there are some things that a root
user can do
that administrator access cannot
for example a root user
first of all logs in with their email
address
and can also have the option to change
that email address something that is
very tightly coupled to the aws account
so you cannot change the email address
with an administrator account
the other thing your user can do is they
can change the support contract
they can also
view billing information or taxes
information that information for example
so the best thing to do the best
practice is that once you've created
your
aws account
you are obviously the root user the best
thing to do is to enable multi-factor
authentication
store away those keys
in a secure location and your first
administrative task should be to create
an administrator super user
from which that point on you will log in
as only an administrative user and you
will create other type of administrative
users and those administrative users
will create other i am users so never
log into your aws account as a root user
unless you need to access that specific
functionality that i said that is over
and above a super user administrator
account
so here we have a set of im users and
we could assign
to them directly im policies which give
them access to certain services however
the best practice is to create groups
which is just a collection of im users
and suppose we have
a developer group and a group of
security administrators of course we
could assign different types of policies
to that group and every user that is
assigned to the developer group will
inherit those im
permissions makes it much easier to
manage
your im users this way for um and for
the fact that also you can have users
that can be
assigned to groups as you can see here
but
what's not shown here that is possible
as well is you could have a user that is
part of
two groups at the same time the thing
that you cannot have though is the
notion of sub group so i can't extend
this group and create a smaller
group of developers out of this big
group here so we don't have hierarchical
groups
but we do allow users to partake in
different
groups at the same time so they will
inherit those permissions those im
policy permissions from for example if
user a was part of developers and user a
was part of security they would inherit
these two policy
statements over here
now there is another type of iam policy
and that is called a resource-based
policy so resource-based policies are
not attached directly to for example
users but they're attached more to
resources like
an s3 bucket for example and so when you
have such a case a user group can't be
designated
as a principal to a group that's just
one of the restrictions however there
are other ways to get around that
as i said
when you think of an i am role i want
you to think
that these are temporary credentials
that are required at run time
and are only good for a specific amount
of time
now an iem role is really made up of two
components we have what's called a trust
policy
so who do you trust to assume this role
who do you would trust to even make an
api call to assume the role after that
we have an iron policy once you've been
trusted to assume the role and you get
those temporary tokens what are you
allowed to do maybe you're allowed to
have read write access
to the dynamodb
so
here we have no long-term credentials
that are connected to role you do not
assign
a role to a user the user or service
will
assume the rova api call via the secure
token service sts and with those
temporary credentials we'll then be able
to access for example an ec2 instance if
the im policy attached to the imroll
says that you can do so
so your users
and your applications perhaps running on
an ec2 instance and the awf aws services
themselves
don't normally have access to the aws
resources but through assuming a role
they can dynamically
attain those permissions at runtime
so it's a very flexible model
that allow you to bypass the need to
embed
security credentials
all over the place and then have to
maintain those credentials and make sure
they're rotated and they're not
acquired by anybody trying to find a
security hole in your system so from a
maintenance point of view
they're really
an excellent tool to use
in your
toolbox your security toolbox
so let's take a look at the components
of i am we have the i am policy over
here which is really just a json
document
and that json document will describe
what this user
can do if it's attached directly to it
or if the im policy is attached to the
group whatever
user is attached to that group will also
have
the same policy inherited so these are
more long-term credentials in terms of
or permissions rather that are attached
to your login for the duration of your
login whereas roles are as we've already
stated temporary and again once you've
established a trust relationship then we
can assign a policy for example a policy
that gives you only read only access to
a cloud trail to a role now it's up to
the user to assume that role either
through the console or through some
programmatic means whichever way is
performed the user will have to make a
direct or indirect call to sts for the
assume roll call
now these permissions are examined by
aws
when a user submits a request so this
all happens at run time dynamically so
when you change a policy it will take
effect pretty much immediately as soon
as
the user makes the next request that new
security policy whether you've just
added
or removed the permission will take
immediate effect so what we're going to
do now is just really quickly go to the
aws console and actually show you how an
im policy looks like
so i've just logged into my aws
management console and if i search for
identity and access management should be
the first one to show up i'll just click
on that and i want to show you actually
how these im policies look like if you
go to the left hand side here there is
an entry for policies
and there are different types of
policies that we can filter out so let's
filter them out by type we have customer
managed
we have aws managed and more in line
with job functions that aws managed also
so we're going to take a look at aws
manage all that means is that aws has
created
and will actually update maintain these
pre-established and already vetted
identity policies i am identity policy
so i could further down
maybe
look at all the s3 policies that are
available and we can see there are some
that allows only read only access
there are some that will give us full
access and there are of course other
types here that we're not all going to
explore but let's just easily kind of
take a look here at the full access you
can see it's just a
json document
and of course you cannot modify it since
this is a managed
policy however you can copy it and
modify it in that case it will become a
a
your own version of it and so it'll be
customer defined and so when you go here
and you
do a filter you can filter on your own
customer
managed policies
so over here we are simply allowing
certain actions right we talked about
actions before that were based on api so
here we have an api that starts with s3
so this is for the s3 api and instead of
filtering out exactly specifically what
api calls are there we're basically
saying all api calls so star
representing
all api actions and again there is
another
category of s3 which deals with object
lambda and we are allowing
all operations on that specific api as
well
we could if this was our own customer
managed
ident
policy actually scale down on which
resource which bucket let's say or which
folder in a bucket
this would apply to but in this case
since this is a full access we're
basically
being given permission to
execute
every single api action under s3 for all
buckets we're going to see in the lab or
the demonstration at the end of this
tutorial that i'm going to show you how
to scale that down okay
so that's how an im
policy looks like and if you want to
assign an im policy to a user well stay
tuned for the demonstration at the end
of the video tutorial what's not at the
end of video tutorial is really how to
create a role so i'll show you what a
role is here again there's a whole bunch
of roles already
set up that we can go and and take a
look at here but we can go and create
our own role as well
and i might create a role
for example that gives
an ec2 let's choose choose ec2 access to
s3 so if i click
ec2 and click next permissions
i can actually assign
the s3 permission
right over here just a policy just like
we took a look at
obviously assign it a tag and review it
and i'm just going to call this
my ec2 role
2s3
create the role
and because i selected
ec2
as
a
service it automatically will include
that in the trust policy so now when i
go and i create an ec2 instance i can
attach this role to that ec2 instance
and that ec2 instance will automatically
be able to if we're using the linux 2mi
let's say have access to or full admin
access to any s3 bucket
uh in the aws account so let's go take a
look at where we would actually attach
that role on the ec2
so when you're creating an ec2 let's
just say we go here we say launch an ec2
instance
and we'll pick this ami over here
because it'll already include the
packages necessary to perform the assume
rule call to sts4a so we won't have to
code that
and we don't have to embed any
credential keys
in order to get this running which is
really good which is the whole point of
what i'm doing because by assuming a
roll i don't have to manage that
and i'm just going to pick the free
t2 micro and it is here once you you
know pick whatever you need whatever vpc
and whatnot
then you come to the im roll and you
select the role to be assumed
dynamically now i have a whole bunch of
them here but this is the one that
i had created here my ec2 roll to s3 and
if i go and i launch this
ec2 instance and then i had an
application let's say that i needed to
contact s3 or even if i went on the
command line of the ec2 instance i would
be able now to communicate with the s3
service because
they would use vaping aws would actually
use this role to perform an assume roll
call to get those temporary sts tokens
for me which will then allow me to
access my i am policy which gives me
full access to s3 and off i go so this
is a great way like i said to avoid
having to administrate any embedded keys
in this ec2 instance and i could take
this role away at any time as well so
there you have it a little demonstration
on how to create a role how to attach it
to an ec2 instance and also how manage
and customer
managed policies
look like
in i am
of course there is also the fact that we
have multiple accounts and so
we could assign a policy that will also
allow a user in another account
access to our account so across account
access is something that's very
very well needed and also is a feature
of i am
so when you need to share access to
resources from one account to another in
your organization
we are in need of
an ion policy to facilitate that
so also roles can come into play here
for that
by also assigning granular permissions
we can make sure that we
implement the
concept or the best practice of
the
least privileged access
and also we have
secure access to aws resources because
by default again we have the principle
of least privilege and no service can
communicate with another until
we enable it via im so very very secure
out of the box
of course if you want to add an
additional layer of authentication of
security we have
multi-multi-factor authentication rather
and that'll allow you to ensure through
a hardware device
perhaps
let's say a hardware token device or
your cell phone that has some software
that generates a code that will allow to
identify
you are actually the person that
is
typing the username and password and
that's somebody who's actually stolen
your username and password so at the end
of this video tutorial
we will show you or i will show you how
to enable that
and of course identity federation is a
big thing
where your users may have been defined
outside of aws you may have
thousands of users that you've already
defined let's say in an active directory
or in an ldap environment on prem and
you don't want to recreate all those
users
again in aws as i am user so we can
tie in we could link the
user's
your user database that's on-prem
or even users that have been your user
account that's been
defined let's say
on a social site like
facebook or twitter or google and tie
that into your aws account and though
there is an exchange of information
there is a setup to do but at the end of
the day it is either a role in
combination with an i am a policy that
will allow
to
map what you're allowed to do once
you've been authenticated by an external
system so
the this has to do with
perhaps
like i said ldap
or
active directory and you can tie that in
with aws sso
there are many different
services here that can be leveraged to
facilitate what we call identity
federation
and of course im itself
is free so it's not a service per api
request aws is very concerned to put
security first and so
i am is free
it's just the services that you use
uh for example if you're securing an ec2
of course that ec2 instance falls under
the current pricing plan
so of course compliance like i mentioned
is extremely important making sure that
it's business as usual in the cloud and
so for example if you were using the
payment card industry
uh data
security standard to make sure that
you're
storing and processing and transmitting
credit card information appropriately in
order to do your business well you can
be assured that the services you use in
aws are pci dss compliance and there's
many many other types of compliance that
aws adheres to as well
so password policies of course are
important by default we do have a
password policy in place but when you go
to the im console you're free to update
that password policy make it
more restrictive based on whatever
policy you have at your company
so many features
and so i think we're ready now to go
into a full demonstration and i will
show you how to
incorporate i am users groups
and also multi-factor authentication so
get ready let's do it
i'm going to demonstrate now how to
attach an s3 bucket policy via i am i've
already created a bucket called
simply learn s3im demo
and what we're going to do is we're
going to attach a bucket policy
right over here we're going to have to
edit it of course and the basis of the
demonstration will be to allow a user
that has mfa so multi-factor
authentication set up to have access to
the contents
of a folder within
this bucket so of course now i have to
create a folder just simply call it
folder1
create that folder
and now i'm going to go into that folder
and upload a file
so that we can actually see
this in action so i'm going to select a
demo file that i prepared in advance
called demo file user 2 mfa
i'm going to upload that
all right and now what's going to happen
is eventually when i create our two am
users one will have access to view the
contents of this file
which
should look like something very simple
if i open this up within the console
you'll be able to see well it's pretty
small right now i'll make this a little
bit bigger of course
it says this is a demo file which user
two dash mfa should only be able to have
access to so what's left to do now is to
create two users one call user one
and one called user two dash mfa and
that's what we're gonna do right now
let's head over to im
identity and access management
and on the left hand side here we're
going to click on users
you can see here i don't have much going
on i just got an administrator user so i
want to create two
new users we'll start with one at a time
so one called user one
now by default we have
you know the principle of least
privilege which means this user is not
allowed to do anything unless we give
them access to either the console right
over here which i will do right now
and also if they were a kind of
programmatic user that needed access to
specific keys in order to
interact with the apis via the command
line interface or the software
development kit for example if you were
a java developer
so in this case that is not what i want
so i'm just going to assign console
access and i'm also going to create a
default password
for this user
but i will not allow them to reset it on
the first login just for demonstration
purposes
now over here we have the chance to add
the user straight to a group but i'll
only do that later on at the end of
demonstration for now i want to show you
how to attach
to this user and i am policy which will
give them access to specific services so
if i type in s3 full access here this is
an administrative access to an s3 bucket
if you take a look at the json
document attached or representing that
ion policy you can see that it is
allowing all api actions across s3 star
and also object lambda across all
buckets and i say all buckets because
the star represents all buckets
so it is a very broad permission so be
very careful when you're actually
assigning this to one of your users make
sure
that they deserve to have such a
permission
so i'm not going to assign any tags here
but i'm just going to review what i've
done i can see here i've just attached
an s3 full access
permission to this one user and i'm
going to create that user now
of course now is the time for me to
download the csv file which will contain
those credentials if i don't do it now i
will not have a second chance to do this
and also to send an email to this user
in order for them to have a link to the
console and also some instructions i'm
not going to bother with that i'm just
going to say close
and now i have
my user 1. you can see here
that it says none for
multi-factor authentication so i have
not set anything up right now for them
and that's what i want to do for
this second user that i want to create
called user 2
dash
mfa or mfa rather
all right so now i want to do the same
exact thing as before
i'm going to assign a custom password
and i'm going to go through the same
steps as we saw before i'm going to
attach an existing
managed policy that aws has already
vetted for us
review
create
now right now they're exactly the same
so i have to go back to user 2 and set
up multi-factor authentication
and to do that you have to go in the
security credentials tab
and you'll see here assigned mfa device
we have not assigned any yet so we're
going to manage that right now
and we have the option to
order and get an actual physical device
that's uniquely
made for performing multi-factor
authentication however we're going to
opt for the virtual mfa device which is
a software that we're going to install
on our cell phones let's say so i can
actually open this link just to show you
the um very many
options that we have for that right over
here i'm going to go with google
authenticator so go to the app store on
your android device and you can download
that of course if you have an android
device if not you have other options for
iphone and other softwares for each one
of those so i'll let you do that once
you've installed that software
on your cell phone you can come here
and show the qr code now what that is
going to do is you're going to need to
go to your phone now and i'm going to my
phone right now as we speak and i'm
going to open up
that mfa software in this case the
google authenticator
and i'm going to say there's a little
plus sign at the bottom i'm going to say
scan qr code i'm going to point my phone
to this
square code here this qr code
and it's going to pick it up i'm going
to say add account there's a little
button there at account and it's going
to give me a code so i'm going to enter
that code right now
so once i've entered the code i have to
wait for a second code and that's
because this code on the screen of my
cell phone is going to expire it's only
there for about 20 to 30 seconds once
that
token expires it refreshes the display
with another token so i have another
token now
that's only good for a couple of seconds
again and now i'm going to say assign
mfa what this does is it completes
the link between my personal cell phone
and this user right now
so now that this has been set up we can
see we actually have an arn
to this device which we are going to
possibly need depending on how we write
our policies in our case here i'm going
to show you a way to kind of bypass
having to put that
so now we've got those two users one
with an mfa device and another one
without okay so now the lab is going to
be or the demonstration rather is going
to be how do we allow
user to mfa
access to
this file
in folder one and not allow
user one
the distinguishing factor will be that
user two has an mfa
set up and user one doesn't so based off
of just that condition
that'll be the determining factor if
they can view the file or not so let's
get back to s3
and actually create this i am bucket
policy
and see how it's done
so back we are in our bucket and now we
have to go to permissions in order to
set up this bucket policy
we're going to click on edit over here
and we're going to click on policy
generator to help us generate that json
file through
a user interface
of course we're dealing with an s3
bucket policy
now what we're going to do is we're
going to deny
all users and services so star
s3 is great out here because we selected
s3 up here we want to deny all
s3 api actions we're not going to go and
selectively go down the list
the
specific
bucket and the folder so in this case
here we're missing the amazon resource
name so we have to go back here
and we have to copy the arn of our
bucket right so we're going to copy that
come back
control b
and we're going to of course have to
specify the folder as well so i'm going
to just do slash
folder one
and then i'm also going to do slash
star for all the objects
in that folder okay
so here's the mfa condition that i want
to add though because we cannot assign
the mfa condition up here we have to say
add conditions very powerful feature
here that's optional but very powerful
we want to look for a condition that
says boolean
if exist or bool if exists all right so
there's got to be a key value pair that
exists and there are many but we're
going to look for one
that is specifically
known as multi-factor authentication
present
and we want to make sure that value is
equal to false so i'm going to add that
condition and then i'm going to add that
statement
and i want to generate the policy just
to show you now how that user interface
has generated this
json document for us that we're going to
attach to our s3 bucket what i want to
do is i want to take this in its
entirety copy it
and go back to our s3 bucket that's just
waiting for us to
paste our policy in here okay so let's
see what's actually going on here
we've created a policy again this policy
could have any id it's just a an id that
was given by the
user interface you could name that
whatever you want of course something
that makes total sense and then we have
one or more statements and then we only
have actually one statement and again
you can select any id here that was just
auto-generated by the ide we're saying
that all actions
on the simple storage service i say all
again because of the star
are denied
specifically on this resource which is
our bucket and the folder named folder1
and all the objects within that folder
under the certain conditions
so the condition is
if
you have
a boolean value of false associated with
a key called multi-factor authentication
present and it has to exist
okay
then if that value is equal to false you
don't have access to the objects in this
folder which means that
if you do have mfa set up you will be
allowed access to the contents of this
folder so if we
assign this and apply this to all
principles which would encompass user 1
and user 2-mfa
then let me just apply this
that would mean
that user 1 would not be able to see the
contents
of
our object inside folder one
and user two dash mfa would
so let's go take a look and log into
let's log out first and then when we're
going to log back in we're going to log
in as the individual user 1 and user 2
mfa and prove this
is actually the case
so i am now logging back in as user one
that we created moments ago
and of course if i for example go see a
service like ec2
we don't have access to ec2 we've just
given ourselves access to s3 so this
makes total sense
we're just going to go see what we have
access to which is s3
should be able to list
and describe all the buckets there
because we've been giving pretty much
administrative access
now if we go here to our
created bucket and go inside folder one
and want to actually open up this
document we can see now that that's not
happening okay and that's because of
that condition
that is checking if we actually have a
value
of true for that um mfa
key that we specified okay so this is
expected and this is exactly what we
wanted
now what we're going to do
is we're going to log out once again
and we're going to do the same thing but
with user 2 dash mfa
let me log back in
and then specify the new password we
created
now of course now i have an mfa code
right because i've set that up for user
two so back on my cell phone i go
i am opening up the google authenticate
application
and i have in front of me a new amazon
web services code
that is only good for like i said maybe
20 seconds so it's a little
nerve-racking if you're if you're not
good under pressure you're going to
choke
so i've just entered the code and i have
to wait for uh
you know that to actually work now it
looks like i actually didn't check off
um
not to recreate the the password so
unfortunately
i must have missed that check mark so i
wanted to kind of avoid this here so i'm
going to start
over and
create a brand new password
a little painful for
you know demonstrations but it's good
for you guys to see how that actually
looks like
so because i've set up my
mfa device properly i am able to log in
after i enter that mfa code and once
again if i go to ec2
now i haven't been given the permissions
for easy to have only been given the
permissions for s3 so nothing changes
here
i'm gonna go to s3
and i'm going to go into folder one
of our bucket in question and i'm going
to see if i have access now to
opening up and seeing the contents and
here i have the contents this is a demo
file
which user 2mfa should only be able to
have access to so that worked so now you
guys know how to create
a bucket permission policy
uh that is also known as a resource
policy because it's assigned to the
resources assigned to the bucket
and let me actually show it to you once
one last time here it is and that'll
only allow us to have access to the
contents of folder one if we have
multi-factor authentication set up in
our account so that's really good the
last thing i want to show you now is how
to maybe
create i am users
in a better way in terms of not having
to assign over and over again
the same permissions like you saw me do
for user one and user two
of course now i cannot do anything i am
why because i'm user i'm user 2. i don't
have access to im so once again i'm
logging out and we're going to actually
see the best practice in terms of how do
i assign i am policies to a group
and then assign users to that group in
order to inherit those permission
policies so let's get to it let's sign
up first
so let us go back to i am
and we're going to be creating our first
group
we're going to simply create the button
or click on the button create group and
we'll come up with a
group called testers
we have the
ability to add existing users to this
group so we will add for example user
one only
to the testers group
and we can also add
permissions to this group so we're going
to go here and add for example the ec2
[Music]
full permissions
create group
and what's going to happen now
if we go take a look at testers we can
see we have that one user that we added
and we also have
the permissions associated with that
group so this means now that any new
users we create will automatically
inherit whatever permissions the group
has which is really good for
maintainability so
for example let's say we were to create
many new testers
so let's say user 3 over here
now
of course i'm going to have to go in
this case through the same steps as i
did before
i'm just going to remember this time not
to forget to check uncheck that
and instead of attaching policies
directly i'm going to say well i want to
inherit
the policy permissions that were
assigned to the group
so i'm going to say this user is going
to be part of the testers group
and of course i'm just going to skip
through the remaining
repetitive tasks that i've already
described
and this user three now
is already going to have the permissions
to access ec2
that they've gained through the group
testers
whereas if we go back to user one
this user also has
the permissions from the group but has a
unique permission added to itself
so in this case
you do have the option of doing that you
have the option of adding a permission
over and above
that is assigned to the group to
yourself directly
so this is really good
adding permissions to groups when you
have of course lots of users
in your company
in your organization
and instead of going to them and adding
permissions after permission
you can centrally access this in one or
manage this in one place so for example
if i go back to my roles
groups rather
in my testers
and let's say i forgot
to add a permission to all the users in
this group so let's say there was 20
users attached to this group okay i'm
not going to bore you with creating 20
users and we have we have two now that's
good enough to show the demonstration
and let's say now i need to add another
permission all right so in this case
here i'm going to add a permission
for example let's say based on dynamodb
right so i'm going to get full access to
dynamodb i'm going to add that
permission
and what's going to happen now
is if i go back to my users for example
user 3
i'm going to see that user 3
automatically has inherited that
permission
and so has user 1.
show two more and there they are so in
this case it really allows
for you to easily manage
a lot of users in that group because you
can simply go to one place which is the
group and add and remove policies
as you see fit and the whole team will
inherit that so it saves you lots of
work and that is the best practice so
there you have it guys
you have learned in this demonstration
how to create users
how to create groups how to
add users to groups and manage their
policies in terms of best practice and
you've also
learned
how to attach to an s3 bucket
a policy
that allows you to permit access based
off of if a user has
multi-factor authentication set up and
we showed you how to actually set that
up
when creating an im user so again
permissions tab is where this all
happens hope you enjoyed that put that
to good use and i'll see you in the next
demonstration
so i hope you enjoyed that demonstration
we're just going to wrap things up in a
summary and
kind of see what
was looked at throughout the tutorial we
first started with what is aws security
we took a look at how important it was
across our organization to maintain best
practice and also
standardize that practice across
accounts organization we took a look at
the topmost services
in which we concentrated then after on i
am and we took a look at what exactly
what i am was in terms of i am users
groups long-term credentials that are
applied as i am policies and then the
concept of a role we took a look at the
benefits of im and the actual
terminology used with working with i am
of course principle being an entity
that is a either a user or a service
itself that can gain access to an aws
resources and we actually saw the
different types of authentication and
what we can do to implement
authorization by im policies and also
through the use of roles
so we took a look how to organize our
users into groups and what actually goes
into acquiring
a role through a demonstration we took a
look at how to actually create a role
and attach that role to an ec2 instance
and then we took a look at the high
level features
of i am which allowed us to either
grant access to another im user from
another group implement multi-factor
authentication like we just did in the
demonstration
or
ensure ourselves that we are following
all the compliancy standards that have
been
adhered to by whatever project we're
working on and that aws is there to
support us
so all in all i hope you enjoyed that
journey into i am if you are looking
into
a more thorough
covering of this topic or any other
topic i suggest you take a look at
simply learn's websites and which is in
the description box below and to visit
all the courses that we offer in which
we go into a much greater detail and
more demonstrations and hands-on labs
and all this so i thank you for your
time
i'm signing off and until next time
all the best
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here